see ya there's the kratom king callin
just quit my job don't have another job
lined up kratom King Coleman and kratom
is that thing it's kind of a bootleg
drug kana is this chin to chin quick
King in the state the good cop he's the
first person I ever heard doing crit and
doing a lot of crater was he really mhm
he's still on it
wow he looks the same I guess he looks
yeah he looks he looks I mean he could
be on it I guess you can't tell him
people are on it again [ __ ] trying to
get into like other things the only
thing I was wondering what are some
moments that you have had so just sort
of like push it to your ass and you have
to do something different when did you
know that it was time for a change yeah
man thanks for the call brother uh I
think he well you gotta be working you
know you always have to be working I
think you know I used to live with a
fella for the friend of mine for a while
and his dad used to Tostitos and stuff
at night and he wouldn't you know ever
really talk to us and stuff and he
played tennis a lot but he always say he
said you yeah you have to have a job you
got to be working so the rest of your
stuff you can kind of figure that out
you know you can you can decide within
that within that world of of having some
sort of occupation what you want to do
but first I would go get a job and then
I would make a decision on what you want
to do because that's really the only way
that it works you can't really do it the
other way because then you're just not
doing [ __ ] you're just kind of thinking
about doing stuff and you'll feel better
too once you have a job once you start
showing up for a little bit of time a
little bit of commitment to work and
having to do stuff you're gonna feel a
little bit more it like you'll just feel
a little more inspired so I feel like
that's what I'll do you think that's
what he's talking about yeah I just kind
of grew it was a bad probably a bad move
to impulsively quit your job without
something else lined up although
ironically I did that when I moved out
here
you did yeah I just kind of quit and
moved out here where were you working it
it was called Meister MMA
was a guy he like imported sporting
goods from like overseas and they
branded him as his own mixed martial
arts equipment that's actually when I
got into mixed martial arts cousin Zelda
gyms and stuff and it was cool but it
was just like low ceiling I was like
this guy's first employee started a
business he's killing it like if you go
on Amazon you search hand wraps at
Meister MMA is the number one thing that
comes up there he crushes and so I did a
lot of shipping and then also like cold
calling to gyms because we had wholesale
so it was cool I really liked it but it
was just like I don't know I I went to
college for four years and it just
didn't seem like a future I would always
be like this guy's number two
whereas I don't think he was like he was
more motivated have like a lifestyle
brand like where he had something just
going he could kind of live his life he
was gonna grow some huge conglomerate so
yeah I just it was a ceiling for you
yeah hmm yeah I think man you got to get
into a place for at least you have a
ceiling first and then find a different
Avenue I mean or if you want to chase a
dream I think that's fine but you just
have to be doing it mhm so I think when
do you get to a place where you kind of
met your edge well I mean I think I
think getting to that place and when
you're working and staying busy is a
better place to be there then then
trying to find that place right now when
you're not working one thing I did when
I was working at the job I was like just
searching for something I was really
passionate about I got a job at Acme
comedy club in Minneapolis on nights I
mean it paid like minimum wage you were
just doorman but like I didn't meet
people kind of in the industry that I
still now will cross paths with and like
that was an immediate future like I
wasn't gonna go with acne but I went
towards my passion kinda and then I
didn't notice at the time it didn't lead
to something directly but now because I
did that back in the day it has helped
going forward hmm so just I think just
always trying to be around things you
care about even it's not exactly what
you're trying to do yeah that's a great
point man yeah fine if there's something
that you're really passionate about if
you know what that is then yeah maybe
start somewhere small within that world
you can definitely get somewhere big
within that world you know sometimes it
just yeah getting close to the
world he could he could work at a head
shop that sells kratom yeah there you go
man yeah start you're the [ __ ] kratom
King dude what do you mean you know get
a lawn mower and go cut a crop Rowan
slang a few Saturday evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one